foreign
I do believe that value is real and I
think value is there as part of the way
that we live together and work together
I think it's part of the fabric of
things and I think things that often
look very much like not values for
example the notion of a fact
actually these are deeply I think deeply
normative Notions to say that something
is a fact is to Market as something that
we can trust
and so in in a sense I mean if I'm if
I'm in a knock about mood and why
shouldn't I be it's it's almost cocktail
time
um I'm inclined to say who cares about
objectivity
um it's not that we're looking for some
kind of cosmic
super existing super world
objective truth with a capital T you
know which if if Terry Gilliam was doing
the the um the graphics that'd be the
words truth inscribed in stone rotating
in empty star star-studded space what
that's not what we need even it's there
and I'm an objectivist so in a sense I
do believe it's there but that's not
what we need what we need is something
that we can trust I don't think there is
such a big as objective morality if by
that we mean what philosophers refer to
as realism that is uh the notion that
there is a truth of the matter to uh
moral questions that it's a moral
questions are analogous to factual
questions or to mathematical questions I
don't think that's the case that was
cons uh perspective for instance that's
the perspective of most religions and I
I don't I can't make sense of it I don't
know where those those truths would
would come and how we would find out
about those truths however the the
interesting part I think for me is that
just because there is no objective truth
out there in terms of Ethics it doesn't
mean that ethics is arbitrated it
doesn't mean that um that anything goes
there is also a lot of things that don't
work a lot of things that that undermine
uh human flourishing and therefore those
things are in my book unethical or
Immortal Massimo because
um can't famously said two things firmly
with wander and all the more I reflect
on them one is the story happens above
and the other is the moral law within
and when can says that he's drawing out
a stoic theme
and the stoic theme is the contrast of
order in the universe the macrocosm with
order in the soul the microcosm and so
in stoicism these two things go hand in
hand you have the objectivity out there
the Transcendent objectivity and you
also have the objectivity that comes
from within the imminent objectivity so
I was very struck that Massimo
apparently doesn't have time for the
Transcendent objectivity that if we're
going to discuss objectivity then we
don't need to worry actually with
respect to Simon I don't think we need
to worry about the universal because we
don't have to deal with every moral
conflict there's ever been right now we
have to deal just with this moral
conflict and that's a matter of
conversation and negotiation and I think
that when we negotiate with others
um I'm thinking the kind of approach
that Jurgen harpermask takes to ethics
it starts with dialogue it starts with
conversation and with any luck
we will be able to negotiate terms out
that we can agree to get to live
together by
and I think that some of those terms
that we will negotiate our way to will
inevitably take the form of rules and I
think one thing that trust really needs
and this brings us back to objectivity
and Truth one thing trust really needs
is the rule do not tell lies well but
but in fact we do tell lies all the time
for good reasons I mean that was that's
one of the standard objections about
akantian uh you know Universal rule
against lying uh the the obvious example
is well the Nazi officer knocks in my
door do I lie about him about hiding the
Jew in the basement right so again
that's another situation where the
general framework is okay generally
speaking you don't want to lie but you
need to use your judgment in a specific
case
so whenever you've got
um refugees in your basement Massimo and
whenever the Nazis are at the door you
do tell a lie then right but then I
brought the percentage of cases what
percentage of your cases is that but
that's the case there are many other
cases where I can do the same in a more
you know sort of less dramatic situation
so then then we have to start agreeing
on when is it acceptable when it's not
and and I think it gets complicated as I
said as a general rule that's okay it's
a general sort of 10 10 tending to
behave that way that's okay but I want
to go back to your issue about
Transcendence and sort of universal
objectivity I think that was a little
too fast
um you can't say oh well let's set that
aside we don't want to talk about that
we want the the to talk about what we
need to do right now well yeah but what
we need to do right now is informed by
whatever transcendental view you may or
may not have so I think we do need to
talk about it and I reject the transcend
any transcendental view because I think
the morality is a human invention